You know, everybody, Dr. Kevin Cutters, again, this is session three and a new look at cancer
and we're looking at how your tumor suppressor and your tumor oncogenes work.
So we talked last week that immunity and cancer in normally your immune system should
kill cancer cells and normally that's actually what happens.
Problem is that your immune system really, that's not really the main purpose of your immune
system is to kill cancer cells because cancer cells are actually your normal cells that
are in a rapid replication phase, so many times that doesn't happen.
So we also have this other failsafe method that God gave us called tumor oncogenes and
tumor suppressor and suppression genes.
So tumor suppressor genes are genes that are really turned on in the case of a cancer growing
and to allow your immune system a better chance to kill that cancer.
Tuber oncogenes turn on, these are bad genes, you could say, turn on in the presence of all
sorts of things that we'll discuss and help the cancer to continue to proceed and grow.
If you could think of a tumor suppressor gene as a brake pedal in the car, and the brake
pedal in the car keeps the car from hitting that wall called cancer, so as long as the
brake is down, the car never hits the wall called cancer and a person never gets cancer.
So that's what a tumor suppressor gene is, but there's all sorts of things that happen in
our body and things that we're exposed to in our environment and things that we are exposed
to in our food supply and that we breathe in, that we absorb toxins, chemicals, poisons,
additives, colorings, all sorts of different bad things, that the reason why they're bad
things is they activate what's called an oncogene, when they activate an oncogene or what's
called a proto-ocogene, they stimulate the car to go forward, so they're basically taking
the brake off and revving up the engine.
So even if you have adequate tuber suppressor genes, the brake isn't strong enough to when
the gas is down, so the oncogene is the gas pedal, the suppressor gene is the brake pedal,
so in order to keep the car from hitting the wall, you want the brake all the way down but
you can't have the gas all the way down, also you're going to slowly slide forward.
And anything you do that decreases the brake pedal, you're going to go flying forward
and you're going to end up with cancer.
So is your environment, is it, is it a, does a person have cancer because of genes?
Well, yes and no, a person has cancer because the environment affected their genes, so if
they didn't have an environmental factor that decreased the suppressor genes and increased
the oncogenes, they'd never get cancer.
So what is cancer?
The mutations, the normal proteins that regulate cell growth, so that is stuck on, so they get
this rapid replication phase, there's more than a hundred known oncogenes right now.
You may have heard, a person has, has her two positive breast cancer, the probably one of
the most common that you hear about.
And it all has to do, is that, is that genetic?
Now, if I go in to get that, well, no, it's actually what's called epigenetics.
So your genes, I have a whole presentation on epigenetics, so if, when you see that come
up, I don't know where it is in the program, make sure you click on it.
So I'm going to give you a brief overview here.
There's only 25,000 human genes out of the millions and millions of cellular functions
that are controlled by the gene markers.
There's only 25,000 genes.
Well, how is that, shouldn't there be millions and millions of genes?
Well, that's actually what we thought, there was going to be millions and millions of
genes.
When the human genome was mapped a few years ago, it was almost a humiliation because every
scientist that was saying that everything was genetic, well, this just didn't fit anymore.
But what we found, though, is that environmental factors affect our genes.
They affect the coating of the DNA, so that it, it, it, it codes differently, and there's
a different outcome based upon what is called for in the environment.
So we're going to discuss some of these.
So there's a whole new term that came out about a decade or so ago called epigenetics, meaning
that environmental effects on the DNA cause a change in the coating and change how our DNA
function.
So that's an epigenetic change, which can actually be passed down to our ears.
So I'll give you an example of a common epigenetic defect.
There is a methylation pathway in your liver, which is a detoxification pathway.
It's dependent to put folate, natural folate, to run this methylation pathway.
Now, detoxification pathways are quite essential because anything that you absorb into your body
that circulates in your bloodstream, that your body doesn't need, even if it's a good thing,
it has to be detoxed by the liver.
Certainly, our greater exposure of chemicals in our environment, circulating through our
blood because of smoke, things that we breathe in, chemicals on our clothing, in our carpets,
in our household, in our clead supplies, in our food, additives, coloring, flavorings, all
these things that are not God-made, but are man-made, go into our body and then have to detox
through the liver, detox pathways.
Well, one of these pathways is called the methylation pathway.
Genetically, it should function perfectly, but with the advent of chemicals, certain chemicals
change this genetic structure, and now it is estimated that about 35% of the American population
has a defect, a genetic defect, actually an epigenetic defect in the methylation pathway, and
they would be termed slow detoxers because of this defect, unfortunately, most theories
believe that this epigenetic defect in the methylation pathway happened because of the use
of synthetic folic acid.
So during the 1920s and 30s, white flour came out by easily shudder off the outer hull
of the wheat and exposing greater concentration of gluten, but also exposed a nice white fluffy
substance that we call white flour that is stored easily and doesn't decay as fast as whole wheat
flour, so it could be carried and shelf life goes way up and doesn't go bad on your shelf
at home.
So it became just the wonders of white flour and wonder bread became our staple diet.
Well, one of the problems with taking the outer hull off the wheat is that that's really
where most the nutrition is, so that they started fortified.
So I grew up in the era where our cereal was fortified with essential vitamins and nutrients,
so you grow up nice and strong.
Unfortunately, this fortification was made with synthetic supplements, which folic acid
was one of them.
Synthetic folic acid causes an epigenetic defect in the folic acid pathway because it's depended
on a special type of folic acid, methyl tetrahedral folate, folic acid is not that type, and it caused
this defect that is carried down into my offspring.
So if I have this genetic defect caused from B-consuming lots of folic acid, or my mother
had this genetic defect because she took predatol vitamins, which even today are contained, what's
contained in them is synthetic folic acid, side note, don't take synthetic folic acid.
It causes this epigenetic defect in a great percentage of the population, they actually
pass it down genetically to the next generation.
So we have these epigenetic changes.
So something like her two positive breast cancer is that a genetic defect?
Yes, but in perfect scientific language, it's an epigenetic defect carried down because
of different breakages in these pathways.
So there's a thing to do about this, yes, we have a whole course on that, so just stay
tuned.
So that's part of how cancer grows.
So tumor genes, these ego genes are highly expressed.
So that is why some people are going to be more susceptible to cancer because of epigenetic
changes that they have a greater expression of tumor ego genes.
So they even need to be more careful in how they live their life.
Are there tests, are there genetic tests that you can test for your presupposition to cancer?
Yes, there are.
Do I run those tests?
No, I don't.
Are they good to run?
Well, it is sense.
They can be good to run because you can be scared straight.
This is how you should eat.
This is how you should live your life.
This is the supplements that you should be taking because you have an x-degree greater
chance of developing cancer in your lifetime because of these epigenetic changes that you
have in your tumor ego genes.
So in that sense, it's good, however, if I have to run a test to prove to you how you should
eat, then you're going to the wrong doctor, so I personally don't run those tests.
So what turns on these ego genes?
That's what we really want to know.
I have, if we have these ego genes present, they're possible for all of us, what turns them
on.
That's what we're going to talk about next week in the following next couple weeks.
Concrete causes.
All right.
Talk to you soon.